All right, so we're almost ready to
start reading data from the firebase.
>> The Firebase?
>> Yeah, the Firebase database.
You know, maybe we should all sync on
what terminology we're going to use,
especially since the developer
is just joining us.
It'll be good to get our language
a bit more straightened out.
>> I was just talking to some
of the Firebase engineers in
the office about it.
Let me go over the terminology
that they suggested.
The entire Json object is what we'll
refer to as the Firebase database.
Which is part of
the Firebase app back end.
These here are known as keys and they're
associo on the right with values.
I can also call a specific
key value pair a node.
A key value pair that represents
a key in all the data in an analogous
Java object I might also
refer to as an object.
If a key value pair has
a bunch of objects inside it,
such as this dodge coin key.
I might call it interchangeably a list,
map or a collection.
If a key holds a single value I will
refer to it as a property of a node.
Each node besides the root
node has a single parent.
For example, the parent of
this bit node is lite coin.
Nodes can also have zero or
more children.
The children of light coin are credits,
updated, ask, bid, and last.
Each node is said to have a location
also called a database location
which is identified by its URL.
This is the root node.
This is at the root URL.
>> Well, great, that works for me.
All right, so why don't you and
me actually talk about how to read
data from the Firebase database.